what is the most money that disappeared
out of your hands folks like like
loss has any have you ever overpaid on a
check and by how much okay because
here's what the Pentagon accountant just
did somebody needs to find a pentagon
account Pentagon accounting error
provides an extra
billion dollars for Ukraine military aid
this is whoops an ABC story okay this is
this is an ABC story so let's see what
ABC has to say just a couple about this
a little mistake I mean it's just two
professional teams
here we go Pentagon has admitted to a
6.2 Billion Auto accounting gear and the
value of weapons by the way do you have
the video rap of the lady saying it the
way she just said it very casually sent
to Ukraine over the past two years the
mistake was due to using replacement
costs instead of Book value the Surplus
will be used for future security
packages uh the surplus funds
will be utilized to support Ukraine and
it's counter-offensive against Russia
Ukraine air defenses successfully uh uh
down 32 out of 35 Russian drones the use
the US has provided less than 34 billion
dollars in a to Ukraine contrary to
previous estimates of 40 billion
President Obama has pledged ongoing
support but concerns about costs and
duration of the conflict persists the
accounting mistake will not impact Aid
delivery here's a lady if you want to
play this wow
following up from some announcements
earlier this year during the
Department's regular oversight of our
execution of presidential drawdown
Authority for Ukraine we discovered
inconsistencies in equipment valuation
for Ukraine in a significant number of
cases Services used replacement costs
rather than net Book value thereby
overestimating the value of the
equipment drawn down from U.S stocks and
provided to Ukraine once we discovered
this misvaluation the Comptroller
reissued guidance on March 31st
clarifying how to Value equipment in
line
with the financial management regulation
and DOD policy to ensure we use the most
accurate of accounting methods we have
confirmed that for FY 23 the final
calculation is 3.6 billion dollars and
for FY 22 it is 2.6 billion for a
combined total of 6.2 billion dollars
these valuation errors in no way limit
or restricted the size of any of our
pdas or impacted the provision of
support to Ukraine and while the dod
while the dod retains the authority to
utilize the recaptured PDA this has no
bearing on appropriated usai or Ukraine
PDA replenishment funding approved by
Tom and then people wonder why we are so
much in debt we don't even know how to
for those of you day Traders pick up
pick up an index on defense contractors
because 6.2 billion dollars is heading
out the door to buy more stuff going to
the Ukraine yeah that's insane man that
is how do they make a blunder like that
how do you mess how do you how do you
mess that up I was in first grade and
they told me always carry the one
come on 6.2 billion be so hard on those
guys it's a mistake people make mistakes
like that and they overpay on the bill
that's a pretty big couch that's 6.2
billion dollars
and it's gone for a good cause we're
going to give it to him in the future
anyways yeah so we might as well listen
let's not judge Perfection from our
government employees let's only expect
Perfection from us yeah we make mistakes
like that I apologize we could get fired
and go to jail but if you make mistakes
like then the government should get a
promotion it's like a it's you should
recognize this type of behavior for
people to want to make those numbers I
don't know I just think it's you know
it's it's Lawyers Guns and Money I'm
actually
happy that this happened why for two
reasons
um number one so we can talk about stuff
like this it's like hold on this is
what's happening guys all right question
you know I've said uh vocally I think we
should have some involvement in what's
going on there but there should be some
limitations to the money aspect of it
okay and this is just one of those
situations where it's like all right
guys
you know we support I get it you know
country just can't invade countries we
can't just sit along the sidelines and
say nothing and do nothing but they're
doing there does need to be some
limitations to how much money we're
going to be investing and funding this
operation and here's a situation where
we can point to and say oh say good
night to the bad guy there's the bad guy
like all right what's going on here guys
yeah because and they'll spin it they'll
say well you know we were actually
planning on spend sending this in 30
days from now so now 30 days from now
accounts receivable we'll just backtrack
we'll just deduct that from the
accounting premise they'll spin it but
there does need to be some limitations
on how much we're spending here so this
is not a freaking Afghanistan situation
where we've been end up giving trillions
and trillions and trillions of dollars
and having nothing to show for it well
you know what that's 6.2 billion dollars
would have done to just to help
Americans just give like just to hand
out some of that money or or help some
veterans or help help help some homeless
6.2 billion as and it's just the whoops
that's all all that is is a whoops for
almost for 6.2 billion dollars bro
that's embarrassing and like you said I
have nothing nothing's gonna happen
they're just like hey at least it's
going to a good cause every Thursday
thousands
a stray dogs are put to death
for 15 minutes
but we are living in a time where a
number that starts with a B is not even
a isn't that big of a deal
unless it starts with the T homie yeah
hey if you enjoyed this short Club you
want to watch the whole thing click over
here but if you want to make 2023 the
beginning of the greatest years of your
life I host a conference once year it's
called The Vault conference where 3 000
CEOs executive entrepreneurs from around
the world come together to strategize
for three and a half days this year it's
going to be at Miami Diplomat Resort and
the speakers this year is going to be
Tom Brady he'll be there I'll be
interviewing them Mike Tyson will gudara
the guy that ran 11 Madison in New York
if you run a business if you're a CEO
entrepreneur and executive this is not
an event you want to miss out on get
yourself your spouse your business
partner your running mates registered
and I look forward to seeing you there
click on the link here or see the link
in the description and I hope to spend
three and a half days with you in Miami
in August September take care everybody
foreign
[Music]